hi my name is Marcus creme and I'm a
veterinarian and a comparative
pathologist at idex bio research and
today I want to talk to you about
molecular diagnostics and what they add
how they can be used in health
monitoring for zebrafish colonies so to
do that I want to talk about essentially
six questions that I'm going to you know
try to address one is why is zebrafish
health monitoring important the second
is why is important to get involved in
addressing this issue now as opposed to
waiting until later thirdly how do
pcr-based molecular assays compared to
histopathology because up to this point
histopathology has been sort of the gold
standard for active surveillance for
disease as well as for post-mortem
examination in the case of a death or a
sick fish or an episodic and then once
we understand how pcr and histopathology
provides slightly different information
we want to talk about the practical
aspect of that you know what are when
does PCR makes sense and when does it
not make sense what are the
disadvantages and then sort of how to
optimize health monitoring using both
histopathology and molecular diagnostic
assays so the first question why is
zebrafish health monitoring important
zebrafish health monitoring is important
because it is an opportunity to
prospectively actively conduct
surveillance for infectious agents that
if they gain access to a colony can
cause disease or cause an infection with
no disease that can make studies invalid
or that can lead to certain types of
errors so basically I think of these
sort of as three flavors one and perhaps
the worst is is mortality if fish die
then it
investigators and facilities at risk of
losing fish and of potentially losing a
model which would be very unfortunate
there are there is some there is an
ability to cryopreserve sperm and
zebrafish and I think eventually we'll
get to the place where we can
cryopreserved embryos reliably and but
if if an if it fish is not cryopreserved
a particular model a transgenic or
mutant or double mutant fish and it
hasn't been disseminated to other
facilities and other investigators then
there is always the possibility of
losing a model type 1 and type 2 errors
there are just different ways of
thinking about how results can be
misinterpreted so in one scenario you
can have the dependent variable of an
experiment and you notice the difference
and you attribute that difference to the
dependent variable when in fact the
differences due to a disease process in
a in a fish or a treatment group of fish
or tank a fish a subset fish in the
other case there may be a real
difference there but you're not able to
detect it because there is so much
variability within the treatment groups
that can lead to repetition of failed
experiments lost time and effort and
then ability for your lab or for other
labs to replicate those experimental
results it can cause the loss of a
balanced experimental design and that's
that's the case where you have you plan
to have the same number of animals or
the same numba love number of
experimental units in each treatment
group and certain statistical tests like
analysis of variance are robust with
regard to balance and and unbalanced
design but others are not so robust so
it's important then not to lose animals
and and and disrupt your experimental
design clinical disease is
I think most people recognize that when
there is clinical disease in a colony
that is on study that that's problematic
pretty interpretation of data
subclinical infections when you have an
infectious process going on and the the
fish mounts an immune response to it
there is a change in various aspects of
that animals physiology despite the fact
that there may not be any clinical signs
there may not be any clinical disease
and so clinical infections have also
been shown to be problematic in
experiments and there's more data for
this in mammals then there then there
aren't fish but there are there are some
examples in fish as well zebrafish
pathogens can basically disrupt things
because of the variance factors or the
damage that's caused by the pathogen
itself or alternatively when the fish or
embryo amounts an immune response the
host immune response can cause damage
and we could think about this sort of
like a battlefield analogy so friendly
fire would be you know exacerbation or
reduction of an autoimmune condition we
don't know we virtually we know
virtually nothing about that in
zebrafish although and mammals and
inhuman epidemiological studies they've
shown that infection has an impact on
autoimmunity collateral damage is
basically all of the unintended targets
where friendly fire represents incorrect
identification of a target collateral
damage is the damage to everything else
and that could be damage to the
parenchymal of a tissue or damage to the
stroma and then there's a period of
reconstruction that reconstruction
involves the replacement of parenchymal
with tissue that doesn't have exactly
the same function an example would be
scar tissue or fibrosis there's a huge
energy expenditure
it involved with fighting off of a
pathogen I think we all recognize that
when we get sick we feel lethargic and
have lower energy there is the potential
for alteration of future immune
responses and we'll talk about this in
more detail but as the zebrafish model
expands to include things like
experimental infection studies there is
us this is a significant risk there is a
nice co-infection literature in other
fish species where it shows for instance
that an infection with one agent can
alter the outcome of a subsequent
infection with a different agent we
don't know as much about the infectious
diseases of zebrafish as we know about
the infectious diseases of mammals and
as a result of that it is entirely
possible that you can be using zebra
fishes and experimental infection model
and have unrecognized prior infections
that alter the outcome of your
experiments okay so another another good
picture of clinical signs and why is
zebra fish health monitoring important
now as opposed to important later well I
have here a figure from a recent paper
that was published in and zebra fish and
this used the zebrafish information
network and has grouped by five years
the number of publications and we see
that in the 1990s the use of zebrafish
in biomedical research began to grow
exponentially and then it has continued
a pretty steep upward trend in recent
years so a good reason to get to get a
handle on zebrafish pathogens and how to
think about health monitoring and
transmission of disease and aquatic
facilities is that there's an increasing
use of zebrafish secondly there are many
places where there are more
investigators that have previously were
and there is a desire for certain
economies of scale to have centralized
facilities and that that includes both
that it that means number one what I
have listed second there is there's an
institutional investment in
infrastructure and there are there's
also an investment in infrastructure
from pharmaceutical companies and from
other places so there are new
technologies even competing technologies
to create more sasur advanced or more
difficult more powerful even in some
cases genetically engineered zebrafish
models there's an increasing issues
increasing number of shipments of
zebrafish embryos that could be between
investigators between facilities between
institutions between nations and cotto
Wilson just recently talked about some
of the issues involved with that and
then the second aspect of centralized
facilities besides aside from the
investment piece is that there is a risk
issue so if you have multiple
investigators that our housing fish in
the same facility where they have shared
facilities shared personnel shared
supplies perhaps then there's the
possibility of transmission of pathogens
from one investigator to another
investigator with more ease and there's
also the possibility that different
investigators fish who are genetically
different have an a difference of
different differences in their immune
response and their susceptibility to
different agents and in the amount of
shedding that their fish could
contribute were they infected and so you
essentially can have one investigator
put at risk because of another
investigator and perhaps even at greater
risk than that investigator also with
centralized facilities it's common to
have other species besides zebrafish
examples would be medaka xenopus other
aquatic models and many
the infectious agents of zebrafish can
also infect these other species and so
if you have different species it's
always possible that one species can be
reservoir for an infectious agent that
both species are are susceptible to
infection additionally as I mentioned
because of the technological advances
and because of you know the availability
of the zebrafish genome and the powerful
tools that have been built to develop
the zebrafish as a model the use of
zebrafish is changing whereas it was
once you know a developmental genetics
model where most of the interest was in
embryo and adult fish were housed to
produce embryos and it's still the case
in many labs maybe even the majority of
lives there now are lots of other people
who are using both adults and embryos
and they're looking at things like aging
behavior growth neoplasia metabolism
toxicology and so adult fish are often
at greater risk of confounding
interruption from infectious disease
because most of the infectious disease
of zebrafish that are recognized are
chronic subclinical infections but it
can it is still an issue with with
embryos we know that at least subs and
clinical infections reduce the fecundity
of zebrafish this is shown for pseudo
luminor filia the most common parasite
of zebrafish by Michael Kent's
laboratory and some zima fish pathogens
are transmitted vertically in his
laboratory has also demonstrated that
embryos and larvae are susceptible to
infection and mount an immune response
and the infections in even in embryos
and larvae have significant implications
for the genes that are transcribed and
for the levels of cytokines I think that
this is an important one to think about
because cytokines were originally
described as
chemical communicators in an
inflammatory response or in an immune
response but subsequently we
increasingly recognized that they have
signaling rolls in normal functions
including development and so because
lots of cytokines have both an immune
response rule and a development role
there's the potential for non protocol
variation or confounding variability
this is this is a figure from Mike
Kent's labs recent paper where he
basically demonstrated intra ovum
transmission type of vertical
transmission of pseudo lomas force and
showed that the embryo despite being
infected with Sudha Loma spores grows
and hatches into an embryo that's
infected with Sudha Loma concerning
adult zebrafish most of the infections
are chronic subclinical infections that
zebrafish pick up from the environment
or from other fish and are unable to
completely clear so most of these are a
chronic slow progressive disease and I'm
thinking of pseudo low- Ophelia pseudo
capillary a tomentosa and mycobacterium
particularly mycobacterium kaloni so
these most common diseases are at have
their greatest impact when studies
utilize adult fish because of the window
of opportunity that they've had to
acquire the infection chronic
inflammation is problematic for most in
your research area in mycobacterium and
pseudo capital area have both been
demonstrated to act as tumor promoters
under certain circumstances if you're
interested in the details of those if
you want feel free to email me and and
you can I can send your references and
help with that also you can submit
questions through the QA
a button that you have and I'll address
those questions at the end at the end of
the talk okay so back to the question
why should we address this issue now
well this board gentleman has lost a
wheel and if you look at the rest of his
vehicle you might think that this is the
first of a series of issues that he's
going to have to deal with but he's
probably going to be fairly able to find
someone or find the resources to make
the repairs in contrast to this
situation where this guy he is there a
relatively few number of people and
vehicles that have the resources to
repair this so as the system gets larger
and more complex so potentially do the
do the problems the third thing I wanted
to address was the different diagnostic
testing platforms the different
modalities are the different types of
diagnostic tests focusing on pcr and
histopathology and what type of
information that they allow you to to
learn about the health status of your
zebrafish so i have here sort of four
categories simple direct exams culture
or microbiology histopathology and
molecular tests so i'll talk about them
individually simple direct exams are
going to be things that you they're
going to be a diagnostic test that is
performed by someone who is trained on a
freshly dead specimen or euthanized
specimen and this includes things like
thin clips Gill clips and squash
preparations or impressions mirrors of
organs at necropsy microbial culture I'm
primarily thinking about bacteria here
but also fungi can be important
histopathology H&E is sort of the
initial go to stain but we also
extensively use acid-fast stains
and fish pathology to look for
mycobacterium and there are lots of
other special stains that are available
two pathologists molecular tests come in
several different flavors I've listed a
bunch of them there but basically
molecular tests are going to look for
genetic evidence the presence of a gene
of a pathogen that does not exist in a
host and because of that they're very
sensitive and specific so here on this
slide I have listed some advantages and
disadvantages for each it's not an
exhaustive list but I just try to get
some of the big ones on there the simple
direct exam is very rapid it is
insensitive in some cases it requires
expertise enix and experience so dark
there are two things here and also with
histopathology that number one you need
to know what to look for and then
secondly you have to have seen it often
enough that you recognize it when it's
there and a significant disadvantage of
a simple direct exam as if there is no
other test then it's a perishable sample
you can't go back to a skin scrape a
month later and reevaluate it at least
kept you might be able to reevaluate a
picture that you took that you can't go
back and look at the original sample
microbial culture is very very specific
it can in some situations be insensitive
in some cases the sensitivity can be
very high and the turnaround time is
variable I should probably also have
included experience and expertise for
microbiology because when we're talking
about microbiology of aquatic species
there is there's a certain amount of
experience and knowledge that is
required that is different than what is
common for a mammalian microbiology lab
so in our lab we have you know half a
dozen specialized select media that we
use for aquatic organisms and we
incubate them at a different temperature
and we hang on to the plates much
longer because some species that are
infectious to zebra fish and other
aquatic organisms take maybe even weeks
to to get pinpoint colonies also there's
some variability in different diagnostic
slabs labs ability to ID reliably the
bacteria that they culture and the
recent availability of mass spectrometry
is a great improvement of our
biochemical tests because there's so
much because there's so much variability
among strains with regard to biochemical
tests we found mass spectrometry to be
much more effective in our laboratory
histopathology can be very specific it
gives you a lot of information it gives
you a lot of information about tissue
architecture it the sensitivity can can
be variable so it depends on if the
pathogen has a creates a focal or
multifocal or diffusely ssion whether it
is a pathogen that's large enough to be
seen for example a parasite versus a
virus and sample quality is is very
important for molecular tests molecular
tests offer extreme sensitivity and
extreme specificity they also offer a
very fast turnaround time relative to
these other diagnostic platforms but the
reagents are more expensive so this is a
view from a fire tower in the Great
Smoky Mountains so this is close to
where I grew up and I like this picture
because it is useful as a metaphor for
histopathology so from up here in this
fire tower you know prior to the more
sophisticated electronics and radar a
person could sit and watch for forest
fires for smoke or for fire so if you
saw smoke you could that would be an
indirect test and if you actually saw
the fire then that would be a
test and there is lots of information
here a whole landscape of information
and you might there might be lots of
other things that you could see that
we're not what you set out to look for
so in addition to fire and smoke you can
see lots of other things going on and
that's very similar to histopathology so
histopathology is both a direct test you
can see pathogens on histopathology and
it's an indirect test because it detects
things like inflammation damage to other
tissues and remodeling that provides
some evidence that either a pathogen is
there or a pathogen who's been there or
there is something else that needs to be
considered or looked into so through
this microscope lens I'm going to
demonstrate that for some agents
histopathology can be very specific so
in this case if you find a large
nematode that has its interior and
borrowing in the mucosa of a zebrafish
intestine you can know with confidence
that you're looking at pseudo capillary
automa tosa once you've seen it often
enough to recognize it when it's there
in contrast histopathology is not always
very specific in this case I have a
small focal granuloma that contains
acid-fast bacterial rods in this case it
was mycobacterium Cologne a but it you
can't say from histopathology alone with
very high confidence that whether it's
actually mycobacterium Cologne a or home
autumn or madam or obsesses or four to
atone because all of them can produce a
granuloma that looks very similar under
certain circumstances and contains
acid-fast gram-positive rods okay so
histopathology doesn't always allow you
to discriminate among species I could
have just as easily used example of a
gram-negative rod if we saw a
gram-negative rod we wouldn't
necessarily
early know just from the morphology of
the bacteria I'm on histopathology for
every species what it might be okay this
is another picture of an acid-fast stain
of zebrafish and there's no infectious
Legion here at all but it's just to
remind me to point out that it can be
insensitive so you can have a focal
lesion or even a multifocal lesion that
doesn't make the plane of section okay
so if you have if you have a parasite
somewhere and the fish but its focal
these are only going to have a finite
number of sections through the fish and
if you don't get the the parasite or the
granuloma in the plane of one of those
sections then you're going to miss it
and so for that reason histopathology
can be insensitive so once again
histopathology gives you a lot of
information so we're looking for fire
we're looking for smoke but if you look
at this landscape of information you can
also see things that you aren't looking
for so with the good pair of binoculars
and a little practice you may be able to
see deer or other animals along the edge
of this river i'm going to show you now
the exact same image from the same place
in the fire tower using pcr this is what
you would see okay so you see whatever
it is you're looking for in this case
dear you see it very clearly so you have
a great capacity to find it sensitivity
and you can be very confident that it is
what you're looking for which is
specificity but you can't see the bear
in this picture you can't see the bear
because your primers and probes were
designed to deer and so as a result
while pcr is exquisitely sensitive and
specific it doesn't give you as much
other information there's no information
about which tissue is affected there's
no information about other pathogens
that may be present that weren't
included in your essay or panel
okay so based on the different types of
information that we can obtain from
histopathology and from pcr when does it
make sense to use pcr for health
monitoring well let's talk first of all
about what health monitoring is for so
we want to protect zebrafish health we
want to take the validity of science
that's being done we want to determine
what the appropriate biosecurity
measures are for to prevent spread and
introduction we want to cooperate with
the legal requirements and with other
institutions requirements for import and
export and we want to protect staff and
and investigators from Zoe nautic
disease so in order to do that we can we
can leverage pcr and it has some
incredible strengths its sensitivity and
specificity that we've already talked
about and then additionally pcr is
useful to test a variety of sample types
for which histopathology would be just
wouldn't be logistically possible so you
can test fish you can test embryos you
can test live feeds and you can test
environmental samples for PCO using pcr
when it comes to testing fish I think
the most sophisticated approach is to
use a sentinel health monitoring program
similar to what is commonly employed for
rodent colonies and so you basically are
going to increase the likelihood of
detection of an agent by having a
disproportionate exposure to a small
group of fish your sentinels and that
way you use fewer animals to have a
greater likelihood of detection however
if if you have an outbreak of disease
those diseased fish that are euthanized
or fish even that are found dead in the
morning or found dead in the tank at
some other time are still useful samples
because DNA is is relatively stable
whereas a fish
where DNA does degrade for sure right
but whereas a fish that is dead rapidly
authorizes and becomes very difficult or
impossible to interpret for
histopathology found dead fish can be
frozen and still provide useful
information on a PC our panel to see
what agents were present in the infected
fish embryos there are certain
weaknesses of testing embryos but it's
not practical really to look at embryos
by histopathology I mean it can be done
but it's not practical in a routine
sense but PCR works well from zebrafish
embryos the biggest question is is how
to obtain a truly representative sample
so if you're testing a certain number of
embryos and you're going to introduce
the rest of the embryos into a system do
the the number that you test truly
represent what you're going to introduce
and part of the problem with that is
that we've learned that when vertical
transmission happens it's often a rare
event and so but it is better it is
better than nothing right so there is
some advantage there live feeds the big
concern with live feeds is usually
mycobacterium so there is a paper it
wasn't a zebrafish related paper but
there is a paper that points out that
brine shrimp path tested positive for
mycobacterium we know that paramecia and
road first can pick up mycobacterium
from the environment and then when you
feed them to fish transfer mycobacterium
to the fish so if you have if you raise
your own live feeds and have your own
live cultures then testing of live feeds
is a is something that pcr offers that
is a way to help protect your colony
guard yourself against risk of
introduction and pathogens that wasn't
previously available
also there's the possibility of testing
environmental samples so mycobacterium
is very much a biofilm bug if you have
well-designed sensitive and specific
assays you can look for the specific the
species of mycobacterium that you're
interested in namely those that cause
disease or at least those that infect
zebrafish there are also likely to be
other mycobacterium species present that
have not yet been and may never be
associated with disease and zebrafish so
environmental samples is another is
another sample type what are the
disadvantages of PCR well the exquisite
sensitivity is a two-sided coin it's
both extremely powerful in terms of your
ability to detect an infectious agents
but also that sensitivity is a liability
in terms of preventing contamination
when you collect samples and when you
handle them in a diagnostic laboratory
so workflow management becomes a sort of
an additional expense to ensure that
there's no cross-contamination you can
have false native results and we're
going to talk more about why that can
happen I'm going to talk about things
that have an adverse effect on the
signal-to-noise ratio and pcr based
assays one of those things is an
inappropriate sample so you test the
wrong sample or you test a sample that
has not been handled or stored in the
optimal way and as a result you have
degraded template and so your
sensitivity is lower you can have
certain inhibitors when you have a
complex sample there are there are
inhibitors of PCR and I have multiple
asterisks around host clearance and we
we often think about this with regard to
viruses we don't know as much about
viruses and zebrafish as we know about
some other pathogens like parasites and
mycobacterium but if you have a
zebrafish that is immunocompetent and is
able to clear an infection then once
that infection is cleared you can no
longer detect it
with pcr because the pathogen DNA is no
longer present and we talked a little
bit about expense so we talked about how
PCR is different than histopathology and
what some of the advantages and
disadvantages are so how can we optimize
it and you know lots of things work at
some level that are not optimal okay so
you can you can you can get some data
doing lots of things sub optimally you
can have sub optimal nutrition that
inappropriate housing distant densities
etc we talked about post-mortem
autolysis of zebrafish zebrafish are
very small as as you know they have a
high surface area to volume ratio they
have a microbiota on their skin and on
their gills and in their gut and once
they die it's not very long before they
oughta lies and so histopathology is
much more difficult on otherwise fish
than it is and a you know properly fixed
sample similarly pcr from fixed issues
is just not as sensitive and we'll talk
about a little bit more about that later
okay so this is the point where I wanted
to emphasize that signal to noise ratio
is important when you talk about looking
at a degraded sample either because it's
been fixed in formalin in the case of
pcr or whether it has not been fixed in
formalin in the case of histopathology
in both cases that they decrease the
signal-to-noise ratio so when you think
about how you're going to use pcr for
health monitoring and a zebrafish colony
you want i want to encourage people to
think about it in a prospective way okay
so excuse me my technical difficulty
there so if you have if you're talking
about you know epidemiology of where
mycobacterium came from and you're
you have an archive of fish tissues then
that's a retrospective model and that
makes sense I mean going back and doing
PCR from fixed issue archives works it
works much of the time it doesn't work
all the time and it doesn't work in
cases where there is a low-level
infection because there is a the time in
formalin the temperature and the ph of
the fixative all have a dramatic impact
on your ability to recover nucleic acids
so when you're thinking about animal
health monitoring and you're placing
sentinels you're being prospective
you're planning so in this case I
understand that many people may want to
use histopathology to screen because
it's much less expensive than PCR if
that's the case I would suggest that
there one option would be to use to do
essentially section of frozen fish in
half we have a method in our laboratory
to reduce priest all artifact so that
it's still useful for a diagnostic
sample and you have the rest of the fish
frozen to go back to for pcr perhaps a
better option is to have more sentinel
fish than you need and either have
additional fish that you can submit for
pcr or have some fish that are
euthanized and frozen and held at minus
80 and after you screen from
histopathology then you can do PCR to
speciated because particularly with
mycobacterium it's important which
species it is the cyanotic risk the risk
the staff is much higher with
mycobacterium marinum and mycobacterium
marinum and mycobacterium home la Flamme
cause significant disease and mortality
in the colony and you certainly would
want to get rid of those mycobacterium
kelowna is very common and it's also
very difficult to keep out and poses
less of a risk to to humans so I want I
want people to
prospective lee when they think about
how they want to use pcr so there are
many publications addressing the issues
involved with recovering nucleic acids
from fixed tissues or from fixed
paraffin-embedded tissues and this is
just a sampling of a few of them so one
that pertains directly to zebrafish
comes from Peterson and Mike Kent and
colleagues and they basically showed
that they were able in their laboratory
to recover nucleic acids from
experimentally infected zebrafish of
different species using different
fixatives and and that's good and it
does often work an experimental
infection is a bit different than a fish
that has a low level naturally occurring
infection I'm not saying that it doesn't
work but it doesn't work optimally okay
so when you do PCR from fixed issues
you're you're making an aftermarket
modification so you want to think about
the factors that are going to influence
the quality of the sample that you're
using for pcr so if it's been a long
time in fixative then that's going to
adversely impact impact your signal to
noise ratio if it has been not been
stored at a cold temperature then that's
going to adversely impact your signal to
noise ratio and if it's been at a low pH
as in an acid fixative then that's going
to adversely affect your signal to noise
ratio so DNA or RNA damage is
ph-dependent now acid fix it is are
commonly used with fish and and the
reason for this is that the acid fit
fixative like d-trix davidson's and boo
ins preserve certain aspects of nuclear
detail that are very important for
toxicology studies so when you're doing
diagnostic pathology those details are
less important you're basically looking
for
inflammation and the presence of
different types of etiologic agents that
can cause disease or or infect zebrafish
so acid fixative are harder on nucleic
acids than buffered fixative like ten
percent neutral buffered formalin also
ten percent buffered formalin is very
commonly available and that is a that is
there's a convenience factor as opposed
to mixing up a fresh acid alcohol
fixative also DNA and RNA damage
severity are temperature dependent so if
if you think you need to go back and
look for nucleic acids and fixed issues
first of all you can you can provide
some protection by embedding them as
soon as possible and and storing in a
cold temperature but commonly you know
fixed issues typically are stored at
room temperature ambient ambient
temperature which is less than ideal so
this car represents your template this
is this is the signal that you're
looking for so the the spinner wheels
that I suggested as an analogy for an
aftermarket modification like pcr from
fixed issue it doesn't make sense
probably to add that kind of aftermarket
modification on template or a vehicle
that looks like this because it's been
degraded after storage and fixative so
the bottom line is in terms of optimal
zebrafish health monitoring is that you
want to choose the correct test you want
to choose the platform that gives you
the type of information that you're
looking for and then submit or test the
optimal sample so the sample that is has
not been degraded either by autolysis or
by fixation in the case of nucleic acids
and with that I will
I can get it to open I will answer
questions so if you have questions
please feel free to send them to me the
first question that i have is can you
test species other than zebrafish and
the answer to that is yes we in our
laboratory we have used pcrs that were
developed and zebrafish on several other
species including medaka xenopus laevis
fathead minnow xiphophorus or or platy
fish and we found that PCR tests work
very well and that in that situation
okay well there don't seem to be any
other questions at this time so I thank
you very much for your attendance and
your attention and my email address is
Marcus creme CR IM at idex calm and feel
free to email me and i'll try to get
back to you if you think of the question
later so thank you very much